Okay Dr. Bell, if you would please introduce yourself to your name and today's date in our location.
Um, David Bell, and today is July 9th.
July 9th.
Okay, July 9th, 2014, and we're located at my place on the Portable and Cabin.
Terrific.
What's the start of the beginning?
You were born in Grinch, Connecticut.
Grinch, Connecticut.
Grinch, Connecticut in 1938.
And were you raised there?
I was raised there pretty much, you know, for my whole life until I went to college.
Can you tell us about sort of your experience of Grinch growing up?
Well, Grinch is an interesting place.
It's a powerful place.
A lot of millionaires, we weren't one of them.
My dad was principal at high school.
And I went to the same high school.
And I think I really learned about leadership.
He was very good.
He said, if you spend more than 50% of your time in your office, you're not doing your job.
So as a student, he knew what was going on.
I was amazed.
None of the students ever gave me any hassle.
They said he was tough, but he's fair.
And he learned all sorts of things.
And he did this by getting down to the trenches.
I mean, he'd go down the border of the room and just talk with the maintenance people.
He'd talk with the people serving up floating in cafeteria.
And he wouldn't ask him for anything.
They would just tell him because they were part of the team.
So I learned that kind of leadership from him.
Unfortunately, we don't see that kind very often.
What were your parents' backgrounds?
My dad was a physicist, went to Yale.
And he became high school principal and physical physics teacher.
And my mother was a pianist.
The concert pianist she died when I was four.
But I can still remember sitting under the piano while she practiced.
And we did quite a bit of camping.
My dad ran a summer camps for churches, Lutheran Church.
And I learned a lot about nature then.
And the respect of nature from these big camps.
And they had a lot of these.
And their idea for helping kids was to get them into nature.
And that's what they did.
So I had that background.
And my beginning of environmental concerns came out of the church background in these summer camps.
Did you have any siblings?
I had three sisters and older sisters and two younger sisters.
How was the household managed after your mother passed?
Well, my father remarried several times.
And he...
I just treated him as a normal household.
He was a very good mentor.
And he had male friends who ran these summer camps.
And I had an anologa who was...
She was quite a doer.
I never thought that women couldn't do anything men could do because my anologa, obviously, could.
So it just, you know, just never occurred to me.
And so, you know, that was the household.
We lived sort of in the country, not quite like this.
But spent a lot of time outdoors.
That was good.
What were your interests as a boy besides being outdoors, I suppose?
Outdoors, building tree huts.
I guess that was it.
I wasn't into... I played sports, but not, you know, not really that much.
So just hanging around outdoors and doing stuff, I guess.
Did you enjoy school?
Yeah, I enjoyed it.
I was not particularly in high school a great student.
Like most kids at age, I enjoyed seeing my friends and seeing my friends.
That's what I did.
What were your first inclinations towards science or engineering?
Oh, I don't know.
I think I was always... I want to do something.
And so I don't think I really...
I mean, I was pretty good at science.
It was interesting.
And engineering seemed more like you were going to do something.
So I just sort of... it wasn't any big decision.
I did decide to go to the Virginia Military Institute,
which anybody knows is a pretty tough place to go, particularly that first year you're rat.
Well, take me through the process of making that decision. Why VMI?
Well, VMI, like I say, it's tough.
I looked around a lot. You know, when you're growing up,
kids, boys, at least.
What's the matter? Can't you take it?
They play sort of those games.
You think, well, when I get older, I don't have to play those games.
As I get older though, I saw a lot of men were playing those games.
Same thing. I mean, I see it all the time at Oregon State University.
People getting co-opted and afraid to speak up.
So I said, I'm just going to go there.
Then, you know, it's tough.
And if anybody says, what's the matter? Can't you take it?
I'll just laugh out of mine. You go through the rat line. It's pretty tough.
So I think that was the way I thought of it.
And it generally worked that way.
It was tough.
You just saw it as a challenge that you wanted to take on.
It's a challenge, that's right.
And I saw it as a challenge to take on.
And I wasn't planning career military.
I wasn't looking for a disciplined life.
It was a challenge.
And I think VMI nurtured that.
You always had a maverick spirit, very rigid, tough discipline,
but there was always a tension there, a creative tension.
And so I thought of the word challenge as a positive word.
And something's challenging.
My eyes light up. Oh, okay.
What are we going to do about it?
And it was a good education. Class sizes were about 2022.
And I had some pretty remarkable people there.
Jonathan Daniels was a martyr in the Civil Rights Movement.
He was a seminary student when he left the M.I.
He became an episcopal priest and he got killed there.
That really jolted the South, unfortunately.
You know, Jonathan had to give his life for it.
But he was quite a person.
He was a valedictorian of our class.
Well, what was the environment like at BMI, especially that first year?
Oh, that first year you were a rat.
That first year and you're on the go all the time.
It's physically and mentally demanding, psychologically demanding.
But all your classmates are in the same boat.
So it's not like they're picking on you.
I mean, you're all in it together.
And there are times of manuals and say,
well, they can't kill me.
And this isn't going to last forever.
Somehow that would get you through.
And I thought of that years later in terms of racial prejudice
because people can't say that.
They couldn't say that.
And when I went back to one of my reunions,
one of the most impressive things that happened to me,
there was an older guy there that was a maintenance person.
And he was black.
And I told him what year I was there.
And I think he says, oh, that's when he began.
And he comes in.
He gives me this big hug and we're celebrating together.
And it felt really good.
It really did.
And they've integrated down there because it was not integrated when I went there.
And they've done a really good job.
And there's men and women down there now.
And so not integrated as in it was whites only,
or there were white classes and white classes.
It was almost all white.
I think it probably was all white.
And just in a South that, you know,
people just didn't even think of it.
And Jonathan did.
He gave his life for it.
Well, when they decided, when they, at VMI,
they figured, man, this is a serious problem.
They really set out to correct it.
And they really did.
And we've had some remarkable graduates, white and black and the patient.
So it was, it was really, you know,
I would say turning point in my life,
I mean, to see that change is wonderful.
What else was expected of students there besides the coursework?
Well, you had physically demanding.
And of course, you're first year, you're harassed.
I mean, you're in the rat line, you're a rat.
And you're on the go all the time.
And so it's hard to describe.
I mean, the Marines respected it.
And I've had several Marines say, yeah, it's tough.
And for a Marine, that's probably about the best compliment you can get.
And it's mutual.
So a lot of physical training and military drilling, guys, didn't work?
Well, there's not a particularly a lot of drilling.
You had to raise that you did and you marched and you wore uniforms.
But the academics were very good.
And classes were small.
And they were, you know, they were academically very good.
So it's just tough schedule.
And physically demanding.
I mean, if you've got a chance to take a nap,
you'd lay down for 15 minutes and go to sleep and wake up and start all over again.
But during the day, you didn't even have your beds down.
I mean, you rolled up the mattresses.
They were up against, you know, rolled up and they called it a hay rack.
That was leaned against the wall.
It was pretty rigid.
But, you know, he's had sort of a maverick spirit to it.
One night we tried it.
We put the evening gun.
90 millimeter howitzer in the PX.
You know, snuck out there.
I mean, there'd be things you'd sort of do that way.
And things, things would happen.
So it was, you learn some things like pulling rink.
That's really bad.
I mean, if somebody does something, yeah, you got ranking.
Of course, a dean or president has to do things.
They have responsibility.
We all know that.
But if they do something, and it's only because I got the rink.
That's pulling rink.
And that's not looked on pretty well.
In fact, they'd have a parade.
And in the parade, there'd be a flanking movement.
The troops are companies.
There'd be tons of going on the line.
And the officer was a kid at officer,
but being in the front with a saber marching in the front.
And there would be tack officers grading the lines.
Well, if he had pulled rink, those lines would just go like this.
And then he'd get chewed out.
So they, you know, if you pulled rink, we'd throw lines.
So I mean, it was, it was just pulling rink was not considered
a particularly good thing.
I see more of it going on at Oregon State University.
And people sort of accepting it.
That's the part that drives me nuts.
You know, someone says something.
Does something that doesn't make sense.
People like and courteous, but tell them.
A lot of times they, you know, they may get upset,
but they really, the best ones know they need to hear that.
But I've seen just too many people with this blank face.
Just don't say anything.
You can't do it.
How your academic life sort of evolved while you're at DMI?
Well, I actually got better grades in college than I did in high school.
And I ended up with a civil engineering degree.
And I don't know whether I had any career,
or aspirations of that.
It was like you're entering a big open space,
you know, you're entering the future.
So I didn't have an agenda, what I wanted to do,
what I wanted to be.
I wanted to do something, do something interesting.
I was more scout, I sort of explore.
And I think at VMI they encouraged that.
You would ask questions in class.
I thought it was a good education that way.
I know we're bad teachers, yeah, but you always are.
But you learn from them too.
Well, you took that education and your first job was with the Division of Indian Health.
Yeah, US Public Health Service.
Indian Health and I went to New Mexico and loved it.
And it was a sanitary engineer, they called them.
And we put in water and sewer systems in Indian pueblos.
And I bring in translators.
And then I got transferred to state of Washington.
And it was kind of funny, because they said, well, there's a project that has a little bit of a problem.
Any time a government agency says we have a little bit of a problem,
that means it's a disaster.
So when I got up there, the project engineer wasn't even there.
And it turns out that some woman had punched them out.
After listening to the stories, I began to understand why.
But, you know, we got the project lined up.
But even there, there were some things, you know, you had to do.
Like, they didn't have enough parts to keep the crews busy.
Well, if you look at the government procedures, it takes months to get the parts.
Your budget's going to be gone.
Or you do that, or you have to lay off the crew.
And so I just went out and told them, wrote a memo and said,
I'm going to go and buy some parts wholesale.
And if this is a problem, please call me.
And then I stayed away from the phone.
So I got the parts, you know, and they were upset because they probably could have saved $30
by going through the GAO or no GSA.
But, you know, the loss of money for the crew.
So I mean, you did things like that.
I love the crew. I love the construction.
A lot of funny stories they tell me and had a good time.
It was good.
What sort of impact did the living in Indian country make on you?
Well, I actually, in Albuquerque, I was living in Albuquerque and I go on the reservation.
And in the state of Washington, I didn't, you know, I live off reservation.
But it was more in the state of Washington, more like rural country.
And I love the culture, I love the dances.
And it was a really good experience for me.
So I, you know, sort of participated in.
I even broke my wrist riding rodeo.
So I had a little bit of, you know, some good stories to tell.
So that was good.
What did you think of the Pacific Northwest?
I've seen that was your first exposure to it.
Yeah. And I only, I was up in the state of Washington.
And I did drive through Oregon and then went over to the coast.
And the thing that impressed me in the coast was it was hard to get down to the beach.
There were so many logs.
I mean, there were just logs all over the place.
And of course, now there aren't.
And I think there were a lot of wasteful timber practices back then.
And the logs were just drifted out.
But so I really didn't, I didn't, you know, I was in Eastern Washington.
And so it's quite different than Corvallis.
I mean, I liked it. I liked the beautiful country.
Well, after a year or two, I think with that job, you went back to school.
Yeah. I spent a little over a year or two years in public health service.
And I went back to New York University, right in the middle of New York City.
Would it change?
I mean, holy mackerel, I'm out in the, you know, out in the sticks and my arms and the cast,
rodeo accident. I'm ending up ending up in New York, middle of New York City.
But I did get a good education there at New York University.
And I got into computer modeling.
And this was back in the mid-60s.
So I got into that.
Fortran was pretty new then.
And I did sort of learn machine language, which was awful.
Fortran, though, was great.
I had a very good major professor.
And I got into computer simulation long before most people.
There were no PCs back then.
And there was no internet.
I used to take cards down on the subway to the Greenwich Village.
That's where the Quran Institute of Mathematics was.
And they had a big computer, then you'd give them the cards and they'd run it.
And then you'd plot by hand the results.
But you got to understand what a model does.
Because you plot them by hand.
You did them yourself.
You could actually see what was going on in the computer.
And now a lot of people don't see that.
They really don't understand that.
And consequently, I think there's a lot of misuse of computer models now.
That's what the things were you modeling.
Lakes and estuaries.
And the thing about estuaries is they're part of the river that's influenced by the ocean.
And the tides come in and out.
They're very dynamic systems of waters changing.
And so before the digital computer,
you had to make mathematical assumptions of steady state.
And the sanitary engineers have been doing this since 1925 on rivers,
building mathematical models long before the scientists were doing it.
And actually, the rivers got better.
They did a lot.
There was a lot of good.
And that's sort of been airbrushed out of the history.
We may come back to that later because there was a lot of environmental improvements on rivers, in particular, that occurred there.
And I was part of that history.
But the 60s, things were changing.
We knew things were changing.
We saw lakes were having problems.
We saw all sorts of problems.
And so that was a real era of transformation when I got here.
And the computer and a pretty exciting time.
Was this also your first experience of teaching?
Yeah, my first experience in teaching formally,
I used to do some help sessions for some of my classmates back in the M.I.
And my family has a lot of teachers.
And so, you know, I loved it.
So I had, you know, I loved the students and the teaching.
And I liked the research.
I don't like proposal writing.
We'll come back to that later.
Tell me about living in New York City in the 60s.
Well, you know, I was mainly involved in graduate school.
And there were some protests.
I generally was not part of that.
My part of the protest, I was part of, in a sense,
of let's do something about the problems.
And mainly pollution.
And certainly Martin Luther King Jr. had a profound effect on me.
This is a huge transformation.
And it was, that was a good time.
I think that what happened a little bit after that,
the drug scene and other things, I just, I felt like that was very different,
very self-indulgent, and often destructive.
And so I really, I had mixed feelings.
I really identified, yes, let's make the world a better place.
But there also seemed to be sort of self-centered naiveness
that was associated with this.
And maybe a tendency to blame other people rather than saying what can we do.
So I had a mix, it was a mixed feeling, mixed bag.
Was this, is it fair to say this was sort of the beginnings of your environmental consciousness that come before?
Environmental consciousness came before, came largely through the churches.
And again, that's been a whole history that they don't talk about.
You probably have read that.
You probably took the history of environmental from Bob McDermott.
And that's just not included.
Well, it was huge.
I mean, here my father would have 300 boys out in this cabins out there,
and they had nature counselors.
Across the river was a lake, was a girls camp,
and then there was another teenage camp, a young adults camp there.
And this was a big thing.
And so I was always taught that respect.
And there was also sort of a technology.
Well, it's got some good things, but it's got some limitations, too.
So we also had that.
And when I got here at Oregon State University,
it was the campus ministries that were challenging higher education.
There's a guy John Connor, you ought to just do a separate history on John Connor.
And because he probably did more to change Oregon State University than any other person here.
He was the campus minister at Westminster House.
And we would have classes there on environmental problems,
and appropriate technology was a big thing.
And there were some economics theories, Kenneth Bolding and Herman Daley.
Dick Clinton is, if you interview him, he'll tell you about Herman Daley.
And academia just sort of closed that stuff off.
But at the time in the late 60s and early 70s, it was pretty exciting.
There was a lot of interesting things that were happening.
But that movement died out.
And again, it's sort of been airbrushed out of the history.
And I think this is one of the things that's probably important for oral history.
Because a lot of historians, they study the archives.
Well, the stuff that may be most important didn't make it into the archives.
Because the big institutions basically don't fund that.
And so it sort of disappears.
So we need to have people take oral history and say, look, here's some good stuff.
And it makes a lot of sense.
Kenneth Bolding, Herman Daley.
I mean, you go back, EF Schumacher, small as beautiful.
I mean, these were books that came in books of writings and speeches that were amazing.
I mean, Kenneth Bolding, he's one of the best speakers I heard on an economist.
And he stuttered terribly.
And you'd sit there and you'd first be nervous.
And then you'd realize that it doesn't bother him, so it didn't bother you.
It was amazing.
And it came up with some really good stuff.
I think if we weren't to know how to deal with some of the environmental problems we have now,
go back and look at them.
And Kenneth Bolding, he was a quaker.
Herman Daley, I think, was a Methodist, EF Schumacher, Catholic.
This was a spiritual movement, but it was certain.
It had nothing to do with intelligent design or evolution or anything like that.
That was never an issue.
And so that's a part of the history.
If people want to understand where we're at now, I think we can go back and say there were some opportunities that were missed that happened.
I'll come back to some of those.
Well, tell me about the decision to come to OSU in 1967.
You'd graduated from NYU and you came here.
Yeah, I don't think I singled out OSU for any reason.
In fact, I had applied to EPA.
And they were going to hire me.
And Don Baumgartner was over EPA.
And the hire me on beautification, study of lakes, and also estuaries.
Don was estuaries, anyhow, aquatic ecosystems.
And somehow that position fell through.
So he sent my resume over to Fred Burgers, who was the Dean of Engineering.
And I got this notice, you know, would you like a position here?
So I said, yeah, so I took it.
What was your first impression of the University and of the town?
Well, I liked it.
It's a beautiful campus, and it still is.
I mean, it's a few ugly buildings.
But generally, I think it's a fantastic campus.
The people were good, friendly.
So I enjoyed it.
What was the department like?
The department was a good department.
It was a traditional engineering department.
But I did have some certain amount of freedom.
I started a course on mathematical modeling, computer simulation.
And you look back, and that was a pretty big jump for a lot of the people back then.
Because the digital computer was fairly new, except the military, of course.
And so I had a course there.
I also had a course, a graduate course, got on the books that was something like a philosophy of technology.
So they, you know, they were receptive to this.
And I think my education at VMI helped a little bit because, you know,
if I felt strongly about something, I told them so.
And I think most people appreciated that.
At least they knew that I wasn't going to back off because I was afraid of raising something unusual.
They didn't even occur to me.
So I did get some courses taught then.
And at that time, I had the mightest touch.
I could get research grants.
I mean, I was just, you know, I couldn't believe it.
Now they weren't big grants like you get now.
But I had, on estuaries, I had one.
And then I had eutrification as it lakes.
What happens to lakes? It was a computer simulation.
And I got that.
And I had another interesting one.
And we'll talk a little more about that.
And that was environmental strategies under indeterminancy.
I think that's what the title was.
And they even funded that one.
It was a small grant.
But then the strange things happened.
As my awareness started to expand, the funding agency started to go narrower.
And by the end of the 70s, things have changed.
Things have really changed.
What do you think happened?
Well, that's a good story.
And that's the one the historians have to look at.
Now there are some historians here.
Army Mother Nature, Jacob Darwin, Hamlin, great name.
Jacob Darwin, I love it.
And he's written a very good book.
And it's about how the environmental movement,
or the environmental science, more, environmental science.
And particularly big computer models, came out of the military.
And I didn't know that at that time.
But my background was out of the sanitary engineering.
So it was a whole different background.
And what happened is their way of doing it took over.
And the way we were doing it shrunk.
And so what they were saying is,
well, we'll build big computer models.
I'm simplifying it.
And that's how we'll approach the future.
Well, I was in a computer model.
And I said, you can't do...
I mean, yeah, build computer models.
But you cannot have environmental strategies
based on prediction and control.
The world is too complex.
And so what we did during this study,
what I did during this study,
environmental strategies under indeterminacy,
I said, look, we have a strategy.
It's very simple.
You don't need big models.
You could build big models,
but you need a strategy.
And the strategy is, we will make mistakes.
Okay? That's called confession.
Okay.
And so what you have to do is learn how to make good mistakes.
And a good mistake is, say, reversible.
Good mistakes are, once you learn from,
good mistakes are ones where you don't get painted in a box.
So we came up with a strategy like this.
And it all made very good sense.
And it does to this day.
I mean, you take carbon dioxide, the greenhouse warm.
People still trying to predict their models
are all over the place if you go far out.
But the CO2 impact is almost irreversible.
And it's just shooting through the sky.
So under that strategy, we would have said,
you got to stop.
You can't wait till you find out what the impacts are.
It's too late.
The world is changing faster than you can develop your predictions.
So I thought it all made sense.
So they send, when I write my file report in 78,
and I got a copy of it.
One in the file.
They send the guy out there to look over my shoulder
and write it.
And this is strange.
That never happened before.
And I thought maybe it was because
when Senator Proxmeyer's Golden Fleece awards,
he would ridicule scientific projects.
But I realize now after some of the history books coming out,
the paradigms were changing.
They were saying we want big scale computer models.
And I was in the modeling.
So the guy looked over my shoulder and said,
OK.
And I thought he was pleased with the report.
When he was.
But when he left, he said,
we'll never fund anything like this again.
I go, why?
Our shot.
We don't have a box to put it in.
This is the answer.
Now, I didn't realize at that time that
that's what the transformation was occurring.
You're building big boxes.
They have all these little specialized areas to do certain tasks
to fit them to the models.
And we weren't looking at this.
Now, one of the guys I work with on here is Scott Overton.
Did you interview Scott?
No.
Oh, it's a shame.
He passed away.
But there is a website.
You really ought to take a look at it.
Very impressive guy.
And Scott and I, probably at Oregon State
between the two of us at the time.
We published a paper in 72.
And we probably had a more environmental computer modeling
than any other to it in the university.
And we basically came up with a strategy that was not based on
prediction and control.
And avoid large scale irreversible change.
You have to do that because you don't know what the consequences
are to be.
So when you make a mistake, you want to make a good mistake,
which means you can reverse it.
CO2 doesn't reverse.
I mean, it's up there for centuries.
It's sad.
Tell me about Overton.
Overton, Scott Overton, statistics and forest management.
And Scott, he was very disciplined.
In fact, there were people in statistics.
I think they were afraid of him.
And a good guy.
Very thoughtful person.
Very rigorous.
And he was a few years old in my...
He was a scouting or work too, I think.
And how he can look up his background.
Statistics and forest management.
He just was good.
So we got together.
And we started talking about this.
And we said, let's write a paper on it.
And it was published in the American Society Civil Engineers,
a sanitary engineering division.
It really wasn't...
Environmental science was just sort of...
Well, was it really out there?
Scott had a student, Larry Hunt.
And I think, early 70s, he did his PhD.
And he had to do it in forest management.
There was no ecology.
But it was in ecology, you know, PhD.
We had a graduate faculty of ecology.
We were sort of fighting the system.
And during his...
One of his last meetings in March is a group of faculty
from forest management, complaining that he didn't take
the road design courses and the cable design,
all the stuff about logging.
And well, he had a powerful committee,
and there was a dean of forestry.
I think his name was Stolenberg.
And I have to give the guy credit.
He picked up the body language of our committee
that we were going to fight for this guy.
And so he was very diplomatic, but he says,
this time, we'll arrange this so we got him through.
So Larry Hunt was probably one of the first ones
to actually get a PhD in ecology.
So there were other people who had done things in biology.
But it was generally...
It's not, you know, like it is now.
So that was interesting.
I'm interested in knowing a little bit more about the climate
on campus in the late 60s.
Obviously it was raging.
There was a lot of tumult nationwide.
What was your sense of the environment on campus itself?
There wasn't...
I don't think...
I think relative to other places, there was probably less.
But I think some of the inquiry sort of maybe lasted a little longer.
So it's like some other places burn out quicker.
My contact was largely through the campus ministries.
And they were really...
They were really active all the way into the 70s.
In fact, even beyond that.
I can remember having a course over in Westminster House.
And so I knew the...
Colonel of the...
ROTC Colonel, Kurt Rosler, I think, was his name.
And he...
I was probably late 70s, I'm guessing.
And I may have the day off, but you can look him up.
His picture's up there.
And he was a tank commander.
And so this is the Cold War.
And during Cold War, Soviet tanks were...
I mean, armed divisions.
They were powerful.
This was a major concern.
So I brought him over to one of these classes.
And there were a whole lot of what we call hippies.
And in this class.
And he just wore sweater casual, civilian clothes.
And he started talking with them.
And they didn't want to like him.
But they did.
He was a good guy.
And I remember asking him the question.
What is more danger to American society?
The Soviet tank or the American gas-guzzling car.
And he said, oh, that's easy.
It's the car.
And so...
I mean, we had those kinds of discussions that were going on.
They sort of ended late 80s.
We put on a conference on Eisenhower's farewell address.
He warns about the military industrial complex.
But people don't realize he also warned about the university.
The danger is that the pursuit of government grants and contracts
will be pursued so much that intellectual curiosity
will be given up.
We must guard against scientific technological elite.
And then later after that he says only an informed and knowledgeable citizenry
can prevent this from happening.
I mean, he has some powerful stuff.
So we did a whole conference on that.
And one of the things we did in that conference, Craig Walker.
You can interview him.
He's the layer.
He gave you a copy of the book.
We did on it.
He and I wrote a chapter at the end.
And we said, suppose George Bush gave this con.
Because George Bush...
The first George Bush was President then.
And not George W.
That was his father.
And so what we did is we took portions of the speech.
And we just said, suppose George Bush wrote this.
And the only thing we'll change is his warning is not about the military
industrial complex.
It's the oil industrial complex.
And so we changed.
And it's really a radical.
It comes across really radical.
Well, you can take that and take it for his son.
You can take it and give that speech now.
And he was warning.
I mean, is it remarkable with Eisenhower?
His whole life was in the military industrial complex.
And his final warning is warning about it.
I was very impressed with that.
And your sense was always he was falling prey to these warnings?
Oh, yeah.
I think pursuit of research.
It's not just over-su, but I think higher education in general.
I mean, pursuit of research.
I mean, we're graded when I was there.
Research.
I mean, I don't know whether anybody read the papers.
But you sure had to put a list on how much money you brought in.
I think that's pretty, pretty common right now.
And so you bring in more money.
And I said, this is strange.
You know, we're being rewarded for spending more money.
Why don't we say, look, gee, I did all this interesting stuff.
And I didn't spend very much of the taxpayers' money.
I mean, it seemed to me that would make sense.
But it didn't work that way.
Was the paper with Overton in 72?
Is that sort of the beginning of the system's theory work?
Well, the system's theory work.
First of all, in the computer modeling and ecosystems,
I was doing ecosystems.
So I was involved in systems.
I was involved in some ecologist or limnologist,
G. Evelyn Hutchinson.
And there were a number of people,
the ecology, the beginning of ecology.
So I had used some of their work, met some of those people.
And I was coming at it.
But I began to realize that
the rivers aren't the problem.
The trees aren't the problem.
The fish aren't the problem.
It's the human systems that are the problem.
So I began to realize this in the 70s,
maybe even a little before that.
And so what I started doing was studying human systems.
Now, if you're going to study human systems,
kind of, you make a choice.
I'm in a computer.
So I can sit behind a computer, of course,
they didn't have the computer screens,
but now, of course, they do.
Or I can actually get out in the organizational systems.
And see what's happening.
I chose that second route.
And that was actually a conscious choice.
I'm going to collect experiences.
I'm not going to be sitting eventually once they got computer screens.
I'm not going to be sitting behind a computer screen.
So I never had email on campus.
Never.
I have some at home now.
Will Gamble, you can interview him.
I don't know if he will, but he did either.
So we were probably the last ones.
But I'm working with these computer systems.
Now, when you work with these computer systems,
there's a whole level of mathematics today
that you can do non-linear dynamics, emergence,
that you can't do with traditional mathematics.
And I can explain it, take me about three for a minute,
explain it, because I'd have to explain differential equations.
But basically, you couldn't solve the equations.
And what you would do with differential equations,
you start out with initial condition,
you tell the rates of change, and then you can make a prediction.
But with certain equations, non-linear,
particularly if they're, say, three-dimensional,
so you're going to see in space what the predictions are.
You end up with the things going around like this.
It's called chaos.
And you end up with essentially,
the world is just not that predictable.
And then you're throwing complexity.
And so, over to the night, we're onto that, 72.
If you look up the references,
I think the title had one plus one does not equal two.
That is, the whole cannot be reduced to the sum of the parts.
And the other one was a paper by Warren Weaver that basically said,
science does not know how to deal with problems of organized complexity.
So I was into the math, because with the digital computer,
you can approximate the solution to equations that you cannot solve.
So you don't solve them.
You get finite difference numerical methods and approximations.
That's what all computer simulations are doing now.
They don't solve equations like they do in differential equations.
They can't even come close.
But the non-linear behave in weird ways.
I mean, the non-linear world is bizarre.
And it's only bizarre because for several hundred years,
we've been taught to think linearly.
And when you're taught to think linearly,
then when something non-linear comes up, it's seen as bizarre.
So I would meet with a guy, John Goman.
If you ever get a chance, he'd be a good one to interview.
He was a campus minister here.
And the best description of John is he's a medieval monk transported by a time machine.
So he never passed through the analytical age of, say, Newton and Galileo,
the analysis breaking it down into parts.
He thought holistically, you know?
And he didn't have any trouble with this.
We had these discussions for years.
The students would just come and people would come and we'd have these discussions.
And so the non-linear world is a strange world.
It's a world that requires you to think more with the right hemisphere of your brain.
Ian McGillcrest has a great video, people should look that up, the divided brain.
And he says the left hemisphere is sequential linear.
And we have become a dominated by left brain thinking.
I think that's true.
And he describes, what would happen?
What kind of organization would you get if it was dominated by left hemisphere?
And he describes, and as far as I'm concerned, it's a university.
So the right hemisphere system, the world is so, you know, amazing.
There's things emerged.
So anyhow, that's the stuff I got into.
But I wanted to get into it from a human perspective, big organizations.
I didn't want to stay in the mathematical modeling.
I kept teaching, I had to make a living.
I kept teaching the computer modeling.
And I enjoyed it. I enjoyed teaching.
But when I teach even engineering mechanics, I almost never brought in notes.
The interact with the students.
And the best classes occurred when the class went in the direction that I didn't even anticipate.
And I just got to keep my life.
And then the eyes light up when they get something that's great.
It strikes me that you're placing an imperative on getting away from the computer screen
and getting out and interacting with people.
It falls the same model that your father took.
Yeah, I think that's probably true.
Really, he really did.
He majored in physics, which at that time, physics.
That's tough.
Because physics, that time was going through a huge change.
And I brought him when he retired a pendulum.
And it has several magnets.
So it's non-linear.
It doesn't just swing back and forth.
It just goes in this.
And when he looked at that his eyes lit up and he just laughed and he says,
that would have driven my professors crazy.
Yeah, so I did that.
It also sounds like there's a divergence between the curriculum that you're teaching
or being compelled to teach in your research interests.
Oh, it's opposite directions.
If I take my career at Oregon State,
I put all my accomplishments in two piles.
A, that got me promotion and tenure.
It was full professor, tenure, all the rest of this.
A, right over here.
Pile B over here didn't go anywhere within your organization.
Not very, not very far.
The most important pile is B.
You can throw out all the rest.
Now I learned a lot by teaching engineering mechanics.
And you learn a lot, for example, in mechanics courses.
The way we teach the math isn't that important.
You have to teach students how to sketch.
Make a sketch.
It's called a free body diagram.
Ask any student who's taking it.
You have to draw it.
So how do you make a sketch?
How do you think?
How do you do that?
And you engage the students in that, you know, making the simple sketches.
So when I went to study human systems, I'm going to make sketches.
Because you see a sketch is two-dimensional, okay?
You know, it goes two-dimensional sketch.
Now you can make a three-dimensional.
That's not too hard to go to three-dimensional.
But going from one dimension, which is a written text,
to two dimensions is a huge difference.
It's just a huge difference.
I mean, you can talk about something as perpendicular in two dimensions.
And that means this dimension cannot be reduced to this dimension.
They're orthogonal.
Well, in one-dimensional lines of reasoning, you can't do that.
I mean, you can sort of say it, but you don't see it.
So the average, typical book is what?
About a half mile long.
It's all one line. It's only arranged on pages for convenience.
And so that shapes the way we think.
We think in lines.
And the world does not behave in lines.
The world is much more of this way.
Now, if you go on a construction site, and I learned this my first job,
they give you a set of specs, all lines written, and a set of drawings.
I almost never looked at the specs.
I was all over those drawings.
And if you go out on the construction site, watch construction on campus,
and you'll see people using body language, you'll see them taking out diagrams.
They're not sitting around studying texts.
Professors do that, but they could never build a building like that.
Well, I'm wondering if the systems theory, I mean, my impression anyway,
I could be wrong about this, but it was sort of kind of the spine of your work.
And that went off in a lot of different kind of more topical directions,
or kind of current events, e-types, directions, is that true?
Well, my work, I finally, a lot of the work in systems now is going highly sophisticated mathematics.
And the study of emergence, for example,
the best people of biology is Stuart Kaufman.
And he's done randomized Boolean networks.
He did some things that's mathematical.
And it's pretty good.
So, you know, I've done some of that.
But I go, what's the point in all the math?
I mean, if we're trying to understand the world that people are living in,
then we ought to be able to communicate to them,
because they know more about that world than we do.
So, what I do is I make sketches.
Okay?
And you make sketches.
And now I'll do, like, 10 statements on a sketch.
And simple statements connected by arrows, so they loops.
Okay?
And I'll get people, if I can get them to read it,
the people who read it and I go,
you just describe my life.
This is what's going on.
So, one of them that I did was how information gets distorted in organizations.
The classic example explanation we give is blame.
Look at the Veterans Administration.
Okay.
Information was distorted.
So, what do they do?
They fire Eric Shinseki.
I mean, he's got to be one of the most honest straightforward guys you can imagine.
I mean, he's an honorable person.
And I mean that, in the best sense of the word.
And you listen to Congress, and everybody's blaming everybody.
So, what I did is I made a simple sketch
and how organization is a system.
And it provides a context within which everybody finds reasons to behave in their own particular way.
But the system is a whole distorts information.
Okay.
That's what I do.
And that everybody inside of it has a good reason.
And they're ordinary people like us.
So, I've done that.
Regional one in late 70s.
And first I didn't publish it, but the model sort of circulated.
People would send me.
I got a Xerox of a Xerox.
Can you send me a copy?
So, then in 1986, I think it was the shuttle blew up.
And I'm watching television, and I see Richard Feynman.
And he's trying to explain what's going on.
And I go, he's describing my model.
I never studied NASA.
So, I send them a copy of the diagram and this table.
And I didn't know he was dying a stomach cancer.
I think it was stomach cancer at the time.
I wish I would have thanked him.
So, if you want to thank someone, thank him quick.
When they die, he can't.
I'll do it now.
Thanks, Richard.
Okay.
And he read it and he wrote me back this letter.
And he says, I read this table and I'm amazed.
Perfect prediction.
No, I don't use perfect prediction.
But if you're Richard Feynman, you can use perfect prediction.
And he says, I didn't realize that NASA was part of a general phenomena.
Now, technically, if I said that, we say that's a grammatical error, a phenomena.
If Richard Feynman says it, it's brilliant.
Okay.
So, then I started publishing it.
Now, next month, August, I'll be going to Quebec City for the American Fisheries Society to present this model.
Okay.
I had to figure out how to do it on a PowerPoint now because there's going to be 2,500 people.
And I've got half an hour.
So, that's a little, I like to interact, but you don't interact with 2,500 people.
So, anyhow, I draw these models and when people can understand them and they see it,
then they can start telling you, because they know more about the experience in the world than I do,
they can start telling you.
And to a large extent, what I'm doing is I'm providing an alternative to blame,
looking at these larger systems.
Now, it's consistent with a lot of the mathematics that's going on.
It's just that you can experience it in life.
And if the world is nonlinear and emerging, we are experiencing it.
We have to open up our eyes.
When one looks at sort of an abstract of your veto, there are issues that are mostly in the past now.
I'm wondering if what you've just described as, if these are examples of it having been,
that model having been applied in the past of things like space-based weaponry.
Yeah, I will see.
That's an interesting.
About the 1980s, somewhere in the 1980s,
I was really getting frustrated with the environmental.
Because, you know, that's about the time that they started the global warming.
We will make predictive models.
And scientists may say, well, we really weren't, no, no.
That's the way the objectives were written.
I went back and looked at the original documents.
And we'll develop predictive models.
And I said, no, you won't.
So I got frustrated.
So I wanted to learn more about large-scale computer systems.
And that can I understand organizations by just observing.
So I went and I spent six years, Ronald Reagan's Star Wars program.
And I had no funding.
So I could go to the meetings and I didn't have to hustle any money.
And, oh, you go to these meetings and, you know, these consultants, they're always have to hustle money.
And so I could ask these questions.
And I said, I want to see if I can, as a citizen,
if I can find something, make a contribution here to something that they don't see.
And I did finds I did.
I could.
And that's a whole other story.
And involves some interesting characters, including Richard Cheney,
who was Secretary of Defense at the time.
So Richard Garwin, who designed the hydrogen bomb, interesting, really interesting guy.
So I met some interesting people and I did some interesting things.
But I was mainly interested in these human systems and how,
and then large-scale technological ones and how we can lose control.
I mean, the control was sort of often in illusion.
You referenced earlier John Conner in Westminster House,
in the local environmental movement.
You want to talk more about him in that period of time?
Yeah, John Conner was a campus minister.
He had been a minister in Mexico.
Turns out he, I found out years later that he, he knew my cousin in Raton.
I think it was Raton in Mexico.
And he had, John was, was very tall and I had this long beard.
And he just would raise all sorts of questions.
He raised all sorts of questions.
He'd just be bouncing around and he'd sort of stir up the pop.
And we, at that particular time, there was a whole national movement
where theology or mainline churches were challenging higher education.
There's a book on a Douglas Sloan in Columbia University.
It's called Faith in Knowledge.
And probably out of print now.
But it's a very good book.
And they, they were challenging higher education.
And what Sloan writes about is that went on for about two decades.
And Eisenhower's warning is sort of right in the middle of that.
So there was a time in there where people are looking at the problems of technology.
Yes, it has good things, but we have to recognize its limitations too.
And there was sort of this attitude there.
So John played a key role in that.
And he was mainly the facilitator of it.
He was the moderator of the Presbyterian Church, which is, I guess, their highest position.
And he would, you know, he did a lot of interesting things.
But for me, it was like he was sort of at the focal point of the center of the whirlwind,
where all interesting things were happening.
So that was a very important time.
And there were concepts that came up then.
Very, very important.
I wrote a paper published in 2006 on evil.
He said, ah, evil, I didn't talk about it.
Well, this was a secular term.
I mean, it's on emergency evils, the title of it.
And I used concepts from theology in there.
And no one raised any concern.
You know, they were helping us to understand this phenomena.
And basically, I was saying that evil, large patterns emerge.
And ordinary people like you and I get caught up within them.
And in biblical language, that would be bondage and blindness.
You're caught up within it.
And you can't transcend it, transcend the context, the system that you're caught up within.
And horrible things could be done.
And the example I used was the Soviet biological warfare system.
And then horrible, horrible things.
And by some top scientists, so scientists can get caught up in it just like anybody else.
Anyhow, that, you know, that probably has goes back in some ways to John Connor.
It's interesting how often you've been working with church groups.
I'm under French.
It's French and church groups.
I don't go regularly to the services.
There, see, part of it, I'm studying models.
Well, I learned models as a kid.
They were called parables.
A parable is a model.
All models are simplifications.
And what they do is help to clarify some matters of importance, not all.
And they expose their limitations.
Okay?
So a parable is a story.
And what you do is you get engaged in the power you learn as a kid.
You don't think much of it.
You engage in it.
And as you're going through life, you begin to see something.
And that's what the purpose of a good model really is.
That you play with it.
You engage in it.
And then it allows you to become aware of something.
And it's very different than having a big computer that no one knows what it's doing.
And it spits out data.
So in that sense, what I was involved in was had its roots there in parables.
But also in engineering, you know,
scientists act like all the stuff that we build here and all the stuff that comes out of science.
Okay?
And well, I would say yes, but I taught engineering mechanics.
This is Newtonian mechanics.
When engineers build like the buildings on campus, just go watch them.
They're amazing.
They build them on campus.
Okay?
We also use safety factors.
And we don't talk about students don't know about this.
And where do safety factors come from?
They come from confession and repentance.
You know, confession and repentance is an anile awful.
It's not self-blame.
It means you've done something and there's a failure.
What are you going to do?
You admit to the failure and you change your ways.
And that's how you learn.
That's how you learn how to ride a bike.
You don't study bicycle riding, the theory of bicycle riding,
and pass a quiz, a multiple grade, you know, a multiple choice quiz,
and say, now I'm a bike rider, you can get on it and you fall down.
That's how life is.
And so in engineering, simple engineering in particular, if you look at the history,
you see all these pictures of bridges that fell down.
You begin to say, what's going on here?
That's how we learn.
And there's a historian engineering.
And he has some statements.
See, I read one the other day,
behind almost every success is a history of failure, something like this.
Well, that's probably pretty good theology, too.
So there's been a whole part.
It's not about belief systems.
And even churches get that wrong.
You know, the word belief is a modern word.
You know, the word religion, even.
I mean, it's a new word.
I mean, new in the last 700 years.
As a system of belief, it just doesn't make sense.
So what you learned were stories and parables.
And you went out into the world and you made mistakes.
Guess what?
So that's how you learn.
So when I come back to some stuff that I learned in church
and stuff that I learned in engineering
and stuff that I learned in environment,
there are some common themes.
Now, what's absent is some of this foolishness
like intelligent design or things like this.
And this is just a big distraction.
I mean, John Conner had no problem with evolution.
My father didn't.
Now, maybe his father maybe did, but a lot of people did.
Things changed.
So I've sort of been on the fringe of some,
I guess you can call theological insights.
They're pretty cool.
There's some interesting ones.
And they're not about belief systems.
One of the things you find now, for example,
is how Buddhism and Christianity have...
Parts of it just sort of come together
and rediscovered each other.
And you take a guy like Richard Roer,
who's a Franciscan Catholic.
And he will talk about the Dalai Lama,
Techno Han.
I mean, it's just like the boxes we put people in,
it just doesn't make sense.
So yeah.
Tell me about the Swallowed Camel Club.
Oh, the Swallowed Camel Club.
Okay.
Okay, the Swallowed Camel Club.
We had a group that was spontaneously many years ago.
I don't know how many.
The first of the library,
and we were making almost too much noise.
And so we started meeting over
at St. Ansemps,
this Episcopal Campus of History,
because John Conner, our time, John Goldman,
was John Goldman.
And he's the guy that's medieval monk.
And we were, people were,
we raised certain questions and say,
I say, well, are you getting this in your classes?
I go, no.
So if you really want to find out what's being taught,
you have to ask the students.
Ask the students.
So this stuff on complexity,
and all the rest of these big scale systems,
those, you know,
they're not addressing all things.
Not really.
Not in a way that registers with the students.
I mean, the student.
Okay.
So we've had these discussions.
So what are we going to call our group?
Well, there's an ancient criticism of university professors.
You blind guides.
You strain out a mat and swallow a camel.
Okay?
It's Gospel St. Matthew.
Okay.
And it's right hemisphere.
It's got a metaphor.
Blind guide.
You strain out a mat.
Swallow a camel.
Three metaphors.
That's the right.
And he puts them together in irony and humor.
And yet people go, yeah.
So obviously a camel is not the sum of a lot of little nets.
So it's not linear.
So anyhow, we would laugh in sort of a joke
we call it the Swallow Camel Club.
And we're not meeting this summer.
It's going on pretty strong.
The last several months, though, we've sort of dropped off
in part of it.
I've been working on some other stuff.
And part John Goldman has retired.
Physical church has gone through some changes.
So I'm not sure where it's going to go.
But it has gone on for years.
And there's still, I got an email list of 30, 40 people who
belong to it.
And I sent it out.
Did you have any contact with Catherine Jeffers-Sory?
Yeah, a little bit of contact with Catherine Jeffers-Sory.
And Dick Shory, he was in mathematics or husband
and nonlinear dynamics.
But not much on this.
Not much on this.
She's done an outstanding job.
And certainly on not a physical panel,
but making the physical church certainly more open.
The Gays and Lesbians.
And she's really done that and had to fight some battles.
And she does it very, very graciously.
Very graciously.
I would say, I'd love to get.
She also has a PhD in oceanography.
I would also be fun to have in conversation
with the her and the Marcus Borg,
or even Marcus Borg.
Because I would be a little more questioning of science
than I think they are.
It's not that science is back.
It's just that there's a lot of specialization
and a lot of claims.
It does wonderful things.
But not everything.
And we could have an interesting discussion on that.
I want to ask you about a couple of kind of bullet points
from your beat of past research interests
that I think have particular book ability
to people in this state.
The first one is an issue that's been important to folks.
My set of state needs an organ that's destruction
of chemical weapons.
Oh, yeah.
That was an interesting story.
So I got invited on this one.
I actually got paid for this one.
I'm not a whole lot.
But a lot of the work I did I didn't get paid for.
I just did it.
And I make my living teaching.
The United States had millions of literally millions
and millions of chemical munitions stored all over.
And I mean, they say their weapons,
most of them are not usable.
And one of them, for example, the M-55 rocket.
They made half a million of them.
It's about a seven foot rocket.
And it's not guided.
And they don't even have launchers.
And the thing I think tends to go like this.
So they got all these rockets.
Well, what are you going to do with them?
And they have the warheads
with the chemical agent inside of it.
So you've got like a liquid and you've got a birch there,
because it's an aerosol.
So I'm not really a gas.
And then you've got solid booster rocket.
And they've riveted the warheads on.
So they can't just unscrew them.
So they have to get rid of them.
So I was part of an independent team
to review the risk analysis.
Because they want to know whether they should ship them off site
or destroy them on site and incineration
or all the rest of this.
Well, one of the things I looked at was the M-55 rocket.
And they had these big steel insulated containers
to transport them in.
And they had on wood pallets.
So I don't know if they might have had 15 on a pallet.
So they had 15 or 30 inside when it's big.
And they had tests so they could drop it from 20 feet.
And if there's a fire could insulate.
They went through all these accident scenarios.
Well, the way they do risk analysis
is they break it down into different little what's the probability of this.
They assign somebody this job.
What's the probability of this?
And they put them all together to find the probability of an accident occurring,
which requires maybe three or four or five different things happening.
So it's a low probability.
And they had a lot of this stuff to have to pull out in the air.
Like what's the probability of an airplane crashing into one of these igles
or these storage bins?
Well, they have to figure out how many planes crashing and pulling out of the air.
So the one I came up with is
OK, what happens to the rockets if there is a train wreck?
Well, don't worry.
There's the warhead.
You know, we've checked the warhead on this thing.
And the warhead won't go off.
I said, I'm not worried about that.
What are you worried about?
I'm worried about the rocket igniting inside.
And it turns out that when they set up the system,
they didn't put a box for that.
So it goes, oh, that won't happen.
That won't happen.
So you go into a meeting and when they say, oh, that won't happen,
wait for the coffee break.
Wait for the coffee break because then somebody comes up,
why don't you go check?
I've heard this.
They say this.
So anyhow, I end up in Tweli, Utah.
And they're going to go in on a tour
of the incineration.
But you have to wear a cast mask.
And they wouldn't mean to shave my beard.
I said, I don't want to shave my beard.
So we'll leave you out here.
We'll just leave you with this guy.
That's good.
They'll leave you with somebody.
This guy tests these warheads.
Very ingenious design of the warhead, you know,
the fuse, the fuse.
But in the process, I learn that,
but I was concerned is inside, if you have a crash,
and all these rockets start smashing around,
then you take steel and you bend it.
It gives off heat.
So is it possible that in the twisting of the metal,
you'll get enough heat to ignite the rocket?
Because all the rocket really is,
all the booster inside a steel tube
and is a slow explosion.
The gas goes out the bottom.
So I had done some calculations, rough calculations.
How much heat would be given off the puncture to steel casing,
and then how much temperature would rise in the steel
right around it, and compared that to the ignition temperature
of the rocket, and it was higher.
So people would say, oh, there's no data on that.
When they say there's no data,
that may mean we've never seen the data,
or we've never collected the data.
It doesn't mean that there shouldn't be.
Anyhow, I find out that to this guy,
and I get the field notes,
that they test these rockets by dropping 20 of them,
and three of them ignited.
Three of them ignited.
And I heard some stories about them trying to test the warhead.
So they get a guy to shoot a rifle at the warhead,
and sometimes he misses and hits the rocket,
and he shouts, the rocket takes off.
But they didn't have a box to put this in.
So they get the number three out of 20.
So you get a probability three out of 20,
three by 20.
And I said, I've seen that number before,
because I go through all these calculations sheets.
And I come and I find that number,
and they say, oh, that's the probability of a warhead going out,
not a rocket, at least.
It gives a reference. I look up this reference.
And what happened is everybody started referencing everybody else,
and what started out as a rocket ignition
ended up as the warhead.
Going on.
And of course, if it's the rocket igniting,
and there's 15 or 30 other rockets inside a steel container,
you've got a bomb.
Because they can only hold like three rockets igniting.
So we pointed out that to them,
and so that was kind of interesting.
Because it illustrates that the science that gets done
depends to a large extent on how the organization
of it is structured and funded.
And if everybody says, gee, that's an interesting idea,
but it's not my job.
That means it's not being done.
Everybody has a good reason why they're not doing it.
But what happens is
the organizational structure in a sense can direct us
to ask certain questions and not do other questions.
And then when those questions come up occasionally,
people can just dismiss it as not my job.
So we better change the organization.
That's not my job. The organization is too big.
I can't change it.
And so what happens is the problems continue.
Now, fortunately, they've managed to get rid of all of them.
55 rockets. They did not transport them.
So we got the right decision.
We brought that.
And how much of my response date?
We wrote it up.
And how much of it survived through the bureaucratic process?
Some of it did. Some of it didn't.
So I don't know.
But it was fascinating.
I learned a lot about risk analysis.
So that organizational structure.
So they're doing a good job.
I mean, they had to get incinerated because these rockets,
they put a stabilizer in them.
But if that stabilizer degrades and they think it does,
I mean, those rockets go off.
And they're all stored together.
That's not good.
They had literally millions of millions of emissions.
So when you read in the paper of the Soviet Union
and the United States arguing about who's, you know,
have the weapons and so forth,
what they should have been saying was,
here, you take them.
No, you take them.
No, I don't want them.
You take them.
I mean, they were billion-dollar problem.
Okay, potential disaster.
And, you know, that was interesting.
Yeah.
So what other bullet?
I want to ask about Sam and the idea of salmon parks.
Oh, yeah, salmon.
Well, I've worked a lot with fisheries biologists
and largely because once I started studying these human systems,
I didn't get, I didn't get research grants.
So I don't have travel money.
So Sam is a local woman.
We had some very fine people here in Sam.
So the American Fisheries Society back in 2005.
They published it in 2006, but somewhere before then.
They basically said we've been trying to protect wild salmon
and we've spent billions of dollars
and it's not working.
So we want to select 33 people from out the country
and even maybe outside the country.
But mainly Canada and the United States and Northwest.
What would you do?
So totally free to say what would you do?
Okay.
And so I was one of them.
So Bob Lackey, he's over there in political science and fisheries.
He was the director and Denise Locke was on it.
So Bob, so they framed the problem.
The problem is how do we have significant numbers of wild salmon
by the year 2100.
And then he had four policy guides.
And one of them were four policy drivers.
Okay.
That's something that I mean.
And one of them was
people are going to have to change their preferences
or their values or preferences.
So I went through the whole thing and I basically concluded that
the way they framed the problem, you can't solve the problem.
Okay. We're not going to solve the problem.
The problem numbers of wild salmon, that's not the real problem.
The problem is what kind of world do we want to leave future generations?
And the whole business about preferences, I said no.
We're going to get outcomes that no one prefers.
So what I did is I reframed the problem.
Now that's kind of like you're being given a test and you go in and you decide,
I can't answer this question so I'm going to change the question.
You're not supposed to do that.
But I did it and I got to give them credit.
They kept the paper in there.
So basically what I had to do is I thought it would be real easy.
I'll just say wild salmon national park.
That's what we need.
But in order to do that, I had to challenge all the ways
that we're thinking, which are linear ways of thinking.
The international park is doable.
We have all sorts of agencies doing all sorts of things,
like the Corps of Engineers, its mitigation sites.
We don't even know where they are.
If you pull that money together and you could buy up
particularly high flood prone areas, which are the best habitats,
all the way throughout the whole northwest.
And you would have a distributed wild salmon national park.
Even through cities, people want their waterfronts.
So it wouldn't be total natural systems.
And there are a whole sorts of flood zones.
You look at the land of river and you see all these different twists and turns.
The farmers have trouble farming there because they flood.
They plan all these weeds, but they call weeds, which are biologists,
called the natural floor.
It's really funny.
And if you look at the people who are studying floods,
they map out high flood prone areas and we got to prevent development
to something about that.
And then you go over to the wildlife biologist and take their maps
of ideal habitat and they almost overlap.
So it's a no-brainer.
Why don't we just buy some of this land?
And pay the people not to build there rather than putting concrete
or rock root wrap along the banks because it may erode.
So I went through a whole bunch of those things.
And I basically found that we could have a wild salmon national park.
And it would run right through different parts
of the whole Pacific Northwest.
And try and let the salmon come back.
And let the salmon guys.
The biggest resistance seemed to come from the science.
And it wasn't about the science.
Everybody agreed we have to protect habitat.
But they would say nobody's going to support it.
People don't prefer that.
Well, I took that and said, how do you know?
First, it's not about preferences.
The amount of money is pittance.
I took the whole national park budget for that year.
So I don't know.
I may get the numbers wrong, but five billion, let's just say.
And then I compared the bonuses given to Goldman Sachs.
One bank is like 20 billion.
Here's the national park, the whole national park.
Here's the bonuses given to Goldman Sachs.
The year before the whole system crashed.
I don't think the people even in Goldman Sachs think that that makes sense.
But you say, oh, people want.
And then the same year that we finally published this,
maybe it's the special national park's America's best idea.
So basically, I conclude that the reason we don't have that
is because the institutions have framed the problem in pieces.
So everybody can say, it's not my job.
And then everybody can blame everybody else.
And then everybody can focus on their little job.
Now, there is a guy who could be interesting to interview.
I don't know the David Lane.
Because he did his PhD dissertation on reframing.
And he used the same in 2100 as his test case.
And he's got brilliant idea.
He basically said, if there are environmental problems
that we have not been able to solve,
we've probably framed the problem in the wrong way.
It's like if I give an exam question to my engineering students,
and at the end of the exam period,
all my smart students are still trying to solve the problem.
I'm in trouble because I framed the problem in a way they can't solve.
So what he wanted to do was to look back over the history and find reframings
because we will lose them because the institutions framed the problem
in a particular way.
So if someone comes along and reframes it,
everybody may say it's a good idea,
but it gets lost in the institution.
So he developed software to get indicators of reframing.
And he could have a software search through with these indicators
to try to find a radical reframed and identify it.
And he used same in 2100 as an example.
And his indicators go like this.
And then my paper came out like this.
So that's how I got to know him.
So he's working over there with international students with English teaching English.
I'm going to ask you a couple more questions about OSU.
Your research interests in your context, primary context,
it seems we're pretty far afield from traditional civil engineering.
Did you ever feel isolated or like a man about a home on some level?
Yeah, you do sometimes.
The hardest thing over the years,
people act like, well, if you do this, you know,
somebody's going to fire you then, that's not the problem.
I never had the problem.
No, I was fortunate because, maybe because of my family,
but I could teach.
So I get real high course evaluations.
So that sort of protected me.
And because if you're not bringing in research dollars,
it's going to be pretty hard to survive.
But I was able to do that.
So there's some interesting stories on that.
Well, I'll tell you one story.
Some of the Columbia roots study, history study.
And Guy Daniel Hancock and I were subcontractors for that.
I said, this is a dangerous project.
I only want to be a subcontractor for the interactions,
the biophysical interactions.
How does all this stuff interact?
And so we're looking at the project and they made all these grants
and they're out there.
And none of it's going to interact because people are doing their own thing.
So we come up with a scheme where we develop hypothesis systems.
I said, well, we'll have an annual meeting.
And Dan and I put up these hypothesis systems about a problem.
And we'll present it to the whole group.
And I said, we'll follow the Bella cooking rule.
Anybody who doesn't like it gets to do it the next time.
Anybody who can play.
So you end up with these, everybody interacts with me,
end up with these hypothesis systems.
And then you reallocate the funding based upon whether you're going to
actually be able to address these hypotheses.
So it's a learning process.
So there's a story that's going to be a workshop there.
And so the manager of the project,
he says, okay, you will meet for the first half of the day
and I'll do the second half of the day or vice versa.
You'll do half of the day.
So we said, okay, so we prepared this for the citizens advisory group
and there are people in there who are fishermen and local people there.
I mean, they know a lot about the history.
They know a lot more than I do about it.
So we present this to them.
Oh, when we get down there, the manager says,
you do the whole day, I'm not going to do anything.
So I think he was thinking he was going to drop something on us.
But actually, he said great.
So we do the workshop and they loved it because these fishermen had,
I mean, they had ideas on this and we're sketching them out
and they said, now we can be involved in this and we can actually,
you can come to these meetings.
So the meeting ends and we go out to eat and the managers there.
And I didn't realize, we didn't pick up on his,
we're usually pretty good at picking up on body language.
But Dan and I are still talking.
We don't realize how angry he is because this means our approach,
he has to reorganize the boxes and he's got them all lined up.
And I didn't realize how angry he was until we're eating
and all of a sudden he loses it, jumps up and throws his briefcase out.
Which I catch and throw it back at him and he storms out,
well, needless to say, we didn't get funded, but the whole project crashed.
But the interesting part is apparently, if I remember right,
my promotion committee was meeting like the week before.
So on the record, I had this grant.
So I was able to squeak by, yes, I don't know, but I made it.
But now you were getting by a lost track of the question,
how do I feel at Oregon State?
The hardest thing to deal with are the stone faces.
You bring up an interesting idea, something that you think is important
and you get a plank, plank.
And I noticed this when David Lane would go with me as you got the stone face.
And I think what happens is, I'm not sure what's really going on here,
but people become so focused on their little field
that the grooves in their brain get so deep that it just doesn't register.
Or they may say, oh, you'll just have to read our literature.
It's just not there.
So it's been sort of a lack of exciting discourse.
I think that's probably been the hardest thing to deal with.
And that takes a toll.
There is a story on this.
David and Goliath.
David and Big Goliath, a huge guy.
No one wants to take him on, so David, the shepherd boy,
comes up and says, I'll take him on.
The first thing he puts on the King's armor, he can't move.
We put on a lot of armor, we can't move either.
Academic citations and references in the academic language
and mathematical equations, he can't move.
So he takes off the armor, goes there, picks up and gets some stones.
And of course, the story goes, it's nice Goliath.
I said, yeah, but what about the other stones?
Let me tell you that.
See, they lead parts for years, supposed to fill in.
So I'll tell you what happened to the other stones.
This is the first stone.
He missed.
That's what life is about.
You miss.
So then, okay, second stone.
This is well.
He hit him.
He hit him really mad.
Okay.
Third stone.
So this is the one that's most painful.
What's worse than hitting him and getting really mad?
Get it?
Make a shot.
Hit him right between the eyes.
He doesn't even notice.
That really wears on for a long time.
So I'm at the end of my talk, you know.
Someone said, someone who knew the story better.
There's another stone.
What?
Yeah, there's a fourth one.
What did that one do?
I said, I don't know.
I don't know.
So my wife is there.
And I just leave.
I come home.
She goes back and she says, I know what the fourth stone was.
It's the Holy Rolling Stone.
Like a what?
She put on this music.
And it was from a TV show.
Joan of Arcadia or something.
The word God appears to people.
Is the janitor or somebody like this.
And it's like a Holy Rolling Stone.
And so I still don't get it.
He says, he dropped it.
And it became the Holy Rolling Stone for someone else to pick up.
And that's, whoa, that's cool.
So, but anyhow, the painful part is often this.
Being seen that there are some really big challenging problems.
And then just not being able to sustain the discourse.
That's the hardest part.
Well, you've seen a lot of change at OSU.
And this is a season of change for the university as well.
I'm warning you to be interested in your perspective on kind of where the university has come from, where it's heading.
Yeah.
Well, they've done a very good job in the campus and landscaping.
I think the campus and the landscaping is really remarkable.
I think they've pretty much given up on the idea of educating an alert and knowledgeable citizenry.
You have to have discourse in order to do this.
I think they're really very close ties with the industry.
I think Rod Adams, who was the dean of engineering, very close ties in the industry, he's now, I guess, a vice president or something now.
And it's not that that's bad, but it's sort of like it's unbalanced.
And there has to be some other role where the university does some unique things that no one else can do.
And I think they've forgotten that.
And I think they're good people.
They raise good person, Steve Clark's good person.
But what I find in the systems is the systems of DAPS,
so the people who are very successful in them in a sense become part of the system far more than they realize.
They become not just in the system, but out of the system.
And it's just too easy to start believing your own hype.
And that's sort of a danger.
And you need scouts.
You need somebody, I used to tell a presence.
Custer's biggest mistake, it's a little big horn, as he didn't listen to his scouts.
And the scouts, somebody who's not bucking for higher position.
And the only time you really need a scout is to tell you something you don't want to hear.
That you're going in the wrong direction.
You don't need someone applauding the direction you're going in.
And so I think there's an absence of scouts that are out there that are willing to do that.
And I consider myself a scout.
I'm not a leader in the sense I don't have lots of people following me, and I'm not a follower.
I go out and explore.
And that's important.
So we are testing with, I'm always trying something, but with one idea.
And I'm working with Charlie Vars, former mayor and economist and court smith and anthropologist.
And it has to do with global warming.
And we have many, many, probably thousands over here as students from places, particularly China, coming here.
Very conscientious when going back. That's a good one.
So the question is, where are they really learning when they come here?
I mean, this place blows their mind.
This is totally different.
And first of all, they're wealthy.
So it's not the peasants coming from China that I grew up with.
I mean, buy some pretty nice cars.
And they're living in a place that in any place else in the world would be called car heaven.
I mean, we talk about our parking problems.
I mean, compared to the rest of the world, this is nothing.
So they're learning something like being here.
And I think they're learning the wrong lessons.
Okay, they're learning.
This is how things are done.
And if they're in civil engineering, they're probably being taught how to do it.
So we came up with a proposal.
And basically that Oregon State University and the city of Gervales in the canary
would develop some of no-car communities served by rail line.
We have an existing rail line.
That existing rail line goes north, goes right through the middle of town,
goes through the southern end of the campus, and right through a piece of property bigger than the campus.
The university owns most of it.
And then further.
You build a clustered no-car community.
I don't know the scale.
You want to get a scale that is viable neighborhood scale,
so that if you were building a mega city that would be the sort of scale in the neighborhood.
So I don't know, 1,500 to 3,000 something.
And what you do is you involve the students in the design of this.
And in doing it, we are telling them the way we have developed this has been a mistake.
Okay, this cannot continue.
And we are going to do it for ourselves.
We're not lecturing you that you are to do something that we've done.
You know, that you shouldn't do what we've done.
What we're doing is we're asking for your help to help design a viable community here in Carvallis
that would involve students, involve faculty, and some citizens from town.
The rail line is all the way through there.
It's already there.
How could we use it?
What could be the way to do it?
And what we would do is involve the students in lessons learned.
They go look to all of the world.
What were the successes and failures?
There's a couple of cities in China that.
One city that is pretty much a walkable city.
But there's also some disasters in China.
So you learn from those.
Okay, lessons learned.
And then you get some of them to start building a virtual examples of this.
They can take tours.
There is a program where it's a construction program.
I don't know whether you're familiar.
I'm not in the video gaming.
But Atlantic had a magazine.
And of course, it's an imaginary world.
You know, with monsters and all the rest of it.
But they build stuff.
Why not make a real one?
They have 100 million participants in this thing.
That's more than all the university students in the United States.
Okay?
So what you would do is you make this part of their effort.
And what they would do is say you want to understand the local culture.
This is the university town.
We have a campus.
There's some good examples.
How can you build on the architectural success on the campus?
So that when they went back, they'd say,
what's the local culture?
How do we build on the success of that local culture?
How do we do this?
No, we don't need to have automobiles.
And you can serve it in different ways and have viable communities.
So anyhow, we've written up a proposal.
It's one page, both sides.
And then we've written a memo which we gave to Steve Clark.
Okay?
And I got with everything.
Went anywhere.
But we're going to start spreading it out.
And we've been meeting on this for about a year now every week over the magic.
So we're just going to go, I don't know.
But you know, it's doable.
When you look at the satellite photographs,
if they take Google or whatever,
it's Earth, Google Earth.
You look around and you can see this.
It goes right by a parking garage.
I mean, how ironic.
Right by a parking garage.
And then right on through this piece of land,
you can have open space, farm space, all around it.
And then there's another one just near,
you look back at it.
And then you look at the sight of you, the back of it is, you know,
it's about a half-barging space.
It's mostly empty now.
Anyhow, that's some of the stuff we're working on.
Well, my last question for you is as you think about the future,
are you able to stay optimistic?
Okay, this is a good question.
There's a big difference between optimism and hope.
Okay?
And there's a Cornell West,
he's a Theologian from the Hill,
and he's black.
And he says,
I cannot be optimistic but I am eternally hopeful.
Hope requires courage to act when doubt is warranted.
Okay?
Now David Lane found that when he did his thesis.
And when I was in a class,
his honest class, David Lane presented that to that class.
Their jaws dropped.
And they said, why hasn't anybody told us that?
So optimism,
it's hard for me to be optimistic.
But optimism involves what the Buddha's call attachment.
You're attaching to the outcome.
So you don't want to attach to the outcome.
And I realize an engineer, you know,
he's supposed to attach to the outcome.
But an engineer can deal with big problems
and deal with a lot of little ones.
The little ones don't add up.
The little ones may be good,
but they don't, that doesn't mean that the whole is good.
Okay?
The world with linear, that would make sense.
For the world with linear, I can be a great musician,
because I can play great notes on a grand piano.
But when I add up all the notes, it's terrible music.
So the world is non-linear.
I'm hopeful.
And I'm hopeful.
And what you do is you don't attach to the outcomes
and you do something creative.
You try to make a contribution in there.
And you don't.
Of course sometimes it feels bad if it doesn't work.
But I look back.
And if I look at all the failures,
if you wanted to say they didn't go anywhere,
now someone did.
And if I had to do it over again, I'd do it the same way.
So there's no regret.
So I guess if you approach, you know, I'm 75 now.
You approach that age, and you don't have regrets.
And you say, no, I wouldn't trade what I've done with anybody else I know.
That's pretty good.
But if I ask me, OK, well, why don't you list all your accomplishments?
No, I know.
I think that's the right question.
Now, again, that gets to be some theological that,
in Cornell West, hope is a courage to act when doubt is warranted.
And then hope also comes as a gift,
freely gift.
That's what they call grace.
So I don't know.
I was going to turn out.
But I don't have to know.
And the idea of prediction and control is just an illusion.
It's just, yeah.
Yeah, if you're building a cabin, maybe that's OK.
But we're talking about the future of the Earth and societies.
It's just something.
So we need to tell that to the students.
Our generation used to tell that to them.
Well, thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
This has been a lot of fun, and I appreciate you being so generous with your time
and welcoming your home.
Well, I would again, anybody who looks at this,
that the oral history is extremely important,
because there are a lot of things that didn't make it
into all the documents that they're studying.
And they may be the important things.
It's kind of what Sherlock Holmes, a dog that didn't bark.
OK, the stuff that you don't find.
Why didn't you find it?
Well, that can even learn a lot from that.
Yeah, learn a lot from that.
Yeah, we'll do what we can.
OK, well, good.
I appreciate it.
Thanks.
Thank you.